this was the first day in court for the
five former officers and their lawyers
and the first time since Tyree Nichols
death that his family was able to come
face to face with the men seen on camera
beating him for several minutes
following a traffic stop the defendant's
lawyers entered their pleas to the
charges against them
not guilty those charges include
second-degree murder which carries a
sentence of 15 to 60 years the court was
adjourned until May the 1st following
the arraignment defense lawyers
indicated their strategy to the
assembled media one suggested he would
be expressing the fear that his black
client may not receive a fair trial due
to what he suggested was the systemic
racism of the U.S legal system let's not
forget that my client is a black man in
a courtroom in America
this is a country where black people are
incarcerated at five times the rate of
white people a country where black
people are 7.5 times more likely to be
wrongfully convicted of murder than
white people have you ever done that
another defense lawyer suggested that
police officers had to face great danger
in their profession and questioned the
charge of second-degree murder anybody
knows to cause death there's no
definitive information regarding cause
of death at all and so we got five
individuals charged with murder I
represented one and it's an honor
because at this point in time I've never
seen people
jump to conclusions outside the court
Tyree Nichols families spoke of their
determination to see the process through
and be present every day of the trial I
want each and every one of those police
officers
to be able to look me in the face that
they haven't done that yet they couldn't
even do that today they didn't even have
the courage to look at me in my face
after what they did to my son
so they're going to see me at every
court date
everyone exactly and until we get
Justice for my son
amen 20 more hours of video recordings
of the incident have yet to be released
publicly there's still many unanswered
questions not least why Nichols was
pulled over in the first place several
other officers and First Responders who
were present during the beating have
been fired and investigations are
underway into other more charges will be
filed Shia britansi Al Jazeera